hallo Forge comes out late December Mike
you and I got to see over an hour and a
half of this new feature for Halo 5 it's
pretty huge and it's pretty in-depth
this time around especially compared to
him before Mike and you and I got to
preview this with Tom French the lead
designer of forge and he was basically
just running you know us through the
entire mode so yeah let's take a look at
all the new stuff we got an hour and a
half of it but we're gonna concise this
into a you know just a few minutes yeah
so the main things to take away from it
to begin with are obviously it's very
much bigger and there are more things to
do and there's kind of an unprecedented
level of control to give you a reference
Tom French are saying there are a few
hundred objects you can use in Halo 4
this time around there are about 1700
and you can't use them all in one map
because as you can see in the video
there's a you know 1024 object limit but
you could still make pretty huge Maps
with a lot of things going on in them
but at the same time 343 is really
focusing on making it accessible despite
how much bigger and deeper it is and
that comes from new controls just better
visual cues within the environment and
just like small touches all around that
are kind of going to increase the ease
of use for people that are veterans with
forge or people that just really want to
get into it for the first time right
here's an example of the terrain so he
you know he basically group these
together I was able to move them all
together at once not just that but pick
the parent or pick like the center of
the axis of the entire grouping that he
created yeah cuz in Halo 4 you would
have had to say you create something you
really like but then you're like oh [ __ ]
I want to really move it across the map
you have to do piece by piece and then
make sure this the measurements are the
same that they're snapping to at the
same part here you can just group it and
move it across as this huge glacier kind
of thing here was something he showed us
was um you know they also have a wide
range of effects you know it really
stylized your map so here's you know
effects on a pig's eye yeah so say
you're making an industrial map kind of
like something that's really just you
want to really get across the idea of
machinery and kind of these moving parts
and then you put sparks in the wall it
kind of really sells that you know kind
of like almost like a factory or a plant
that you're kind of fighting through and
it really just adds more
helps the world you're creating and
narrows and scope from big to small and
kind of have control over a lot of it so
then we have terrain and tons of
different variations of pallets which
ones we have yeah so you pick a terrain
pallet to begin with and there are four
right now and each of these are huge Tom
French was saying you could build three
or four of your own Maps inside each
terrain pallet obviously the object
count would prevent you from doing
anything too huge but you know
theoretically you could have four
individual Maps if they're small enough
connected by teleporters across these
huge environments you can kind of see
glaciers mountainous areas up until you
see those diamond things in the
background those are pretty much the
boundaries you can build anything you
want inside that making sure you don't
actually exceed the object limit he even
said it like you're not using the entire
map only because it will be a very slow
game everyone would be so spread out
like you're using like just a section
just a certain area oh yeah this Dwarfs
anything you've seen in Halo 4
especially anything in the previous four
just because again they have the more
power to have like include all the
effects you want to do any objects any
you know scripting which is another
thing we got to see the scripting was I
think my biggest takeaway now you find
you describe a little further yeah so
once you have two objects you pretty
much just have to link them by channels
I forget how many available channels are
you know there's alpha bravo charlie
and once anytime you activate a switch
on the Alpha Channel say any other
object on the Alpha Channel will react
in a way that you make it which again
the world the in-game world has these
visual cues to show you what to do so
the cylinder when he showed us headed
this upward arrow that kind of indicates
if you press the switch and it's on the
same channel it's gonna shoot upwards
and it's pretty crazy how easy it seemed
when he did this so I'm really excited
to see what awed me and you and then
tons of players can actually come up
with maybe you know the next Grifball
will come out of Halo fives forward
because of how easy it is to use so
another big ad was features like time of
day so you keno changed from morning you
know
night to afternoon and then even as
something as something maybe you
wouldn't I wouldn't be ideal but you
could do like I like Instagram filters
which were you know you could stylize
make like a World War two themed film
grain or something or you could do yeah
like a green hue if you want to make it
look like fallout 3 some sort of
post-apocalyptic world a lot of these
are all just aesthetics but it's really
just kind of coming down to how you
personalize things but also you can just
completely change the wind direction
it's free in depth how much control you
have over not just a map but what's
happening around you in the skybox and
the shadows and the lighting and
everything it's pretty crazy how much
you can actually kind of make this feel
like almost get campaign mission like
things are happening for a reason almost
and it's not just this static map you're
shooting other players on and to further
stylize it you can also control the
opening and closing cinematics if you've
been playing Halo 5 multiplayer you know
that it'll show your team kind of you
know strike these poses with their guns
on their shoulders or just holding a you
know the assault rifle across their
chest and then it'll cut into the match
you can control what the camera does
there you can pan it and then kind of
zoom out as you're going to make it a
little more stylistic it's nothing
that's gonna really affect the gameplay
but it's still pretty cool like if
you're already personalizing everything
it's just another level of that mm-hmm
and and not even just you know
intro/outro implications but machinima
which was huge which is also really
bizarre to think about because that's
not really a game that's making a movie
so you know he added a chroma key yeah
I'm just imagining you could probably
make the mini green screen into like a
giant movie theater I just imagine red
vs. blue in church watching it almost
and just commenting on like Mystery
Science Theater yeah I'm excited about
it I'm I'm excited about how many more
options there are but also how much
easier it seems like it's going to be to
use because Forge has always been one of
those things you get out what you put in
and I think this is going to make it
easier to devote that time to it so I'm
really looking forward to seeing what I
can create and just more than that I'm
looking forward to seeing what the
community creates and things I can jump
into and play myself yeah can't wait for
all of your gaming news and Halo 5 needs
you go to GameSpot calm
you